all right you guys know how neil's
always donning the van gogh's starry
night painting you know whether it's his
tie or his vest his phone case whatever
he is obsessed with that painting and
rightfully so now you've seen neil wear
the painting but did you know
you can actually invest in it
what
that's right technology is so advanced
these days that there's now an
opportunity to invest in the works of
art that you believe in
of course this isn't financial advice
and just like any other decision you
make with your money you need to do your
own research but you know here at star
talk we're all about discovery and this
is something new that you might want to
look into so let me introduce you to
masterworks it's a revolutionary company
making multi-million dollar paintings
investible that's right investable like
you can actually own a share that
represents an investment in famous
artwork and get this
the prices of contemporary art physical
paintings has outpaced the s p 500 by
over 100 from 1995 to 2021. whether
you're an art lover like me or you're
just looking to research new ways to
diversify your investments go give
masterworks a look hit the link in the
video description below or go to
masterworks dot io to learn more
[Music]
we're back chuck yeah things you thought
you knew you ready for another one i'm
ready let's do it let's go there and by
the way i pick these based on
how familiar we think we are
about the subject
and then throwing some things that you
never knew
see that's the cool thing though because
i mean if we were just going to talk
about like gravitational waves of course
we know we don't know none you know what
i mean like who's an astrophysicist
there's like what 20 of you you know
what i mean you know like seven of you
sitting around you know yeah yeah so
this is not just let me explain stuff
that you can get on the reiki page it's
like no cool fun stuff you never thought
no it's the twist
the twist that gets you man like the
inverted rainbow who knew that the
orders of rainbow who knew that yeah
yeah like i mean that's stuff that you
honestly but everybody knows rainbows
so for this segment we're gonna talk
about zero
all right here we go again
okay now i'm gonna be honest
you
it's it's go this is a this is gonna be
tough for you man
are you ready all right here we go
zero all right so let's do this
so zero
is a number
but it wasn't always a number
in fact no one ever imagined
it could be a number
in fact no one even imagined how to
imagine it
why would you
right
what were numbers for right who counts
nothing
right numbers are for counting right
okay how many chickens do you have three
how many
cattle do you have you count things
so nobody had any
use
to count zero
it just was not there for most of
civilization this was the case right
even through
the roman empire
wow we think of them as highly civilized
the whole cities and hot baths and
armies and if that
equivalent aqueducts and aqueducts right
they were they're so sophisticated their
numbers were letters
so roman empire
they can count they used roman numerals
right we learn roman numerals in
elementary school don't we still i think
right
and the reason why we learn roman
numerals is so that we know how to count
super bowl games
that is kind of the only application one
more one other for some movie sequels
true
true that's it sure that's it i don't
know any other application
okay oh i know also
lowercase roman numerals
are the page numbers
in books before you get to the actual
uh chapters of the book okay yeah that's
true look at the bottom of the pages
those are usually roman numerals and
then they restart from from one and then
okay yeah so i don't know if you've ever
thought about this chuck uh-huh you
can't write zero with roman numerals no
you can't right there is no symbol for
zero
it's not cause they didn't
come up with it it's that the concept of
zero was not yet invented wow
so when they made the julian calendar
that's the one that has a leap day every
four years
and
because they knew enough to know that
the calendar needed it
that calendar the julian calendar
which anchored its
starter date on the birth of jesus
okay so this obviously came later after
constantine i i think constantine
brought christianity to the roman empire
so in the julian calendar they went from
one bc bc of course stands for before
christ christ to a d one and a d is in
latin and o domini the year of our lord
won and there was no year zero in that
transition
so
so
when would jesus have been born all
right and
you know in the mythical
year between the two he can't be born in
ad1 because that's after and he can't be
born in bc because that's before so so
there's a this is an issue oh i got the
answer
it's a miracle
okay
well later biblical research would show
that jesus was probably born closer to
three or four bc
and so but the calendar was already in
place
so you're stuck with that there's a
mismatch there three or four year
missions we got to play this hand we
gotta play this hand bro we've gotta
play okay so now move time forward
going um
is in the 600 700's i forgot exactly
when uh in
india
the great advances in mathematics there
where they even developed the numerals
early versions of the numerals we now
use
okay
rather than roman numerals okay roman
numerals were letters these are now sort
of symbolic shapes
that would then represent
the numbers
and in this effort where was the hint
that maybe you might want a zero in
there
okay okay so we're crawling now before
we can walk but but the seeds are
planted this these new mathematics work
their way to the middle east
okay
and
baghdad specifically a big trading post
from all corners of europe and asia and
africa and there it was ideas were put
across the table that this is the golden
age of islam all right major advances
were made and all in engineering and
astronomy and biology physiology and and
and vision that's where the discovery
that uh in envision
is a passive phenomenon not active and
so all of this is going on and then the
zero
was perfected
oh the zero is perfected they call those
numerals hindu numerals
okay but we today call those numerals
arabic numerals right yeah okay
so this is the full tracking there
because in the middle east an entire
algebra rose up and arithmetic and
algebra rose up invoking zero uh and you
have negative numbers
and so mathematics is off to the races
algebra is one of very common
words in english that has its roots in
arabic a lot of the al words uh al is
the in arabic as i understand it
yeah so
so algebra algorithm right another one
alcohol uh these are all traceable to
that period but all i'm trying to say
the best of which is alcohol
[Laughter]
good going guys there you go wait a way
to do it
so
so i'm just saying zero all
just consider how late zero came
in
civilization the egyptians knew nothing
of zero right the but it's there and and
we've got it and so now what is this
what is this i hear about the mayans
uh and zero that they somehow had
something to do i don't fully know my
mayan history other than that their
calendar was uh they really worshipped
venus in the sky
and so their calendar was sort of venus
based
uh the calendar in
ancient egypt was based on the star
sirius
when i mean i'm talking about the new
year when yeah yeah yeah cause it's
completely arbitrary when you say that
here the new year just began you know
completely arbitrary just pick a date
and whatever matters in your culture
call it the beginning of the year it's
not you know to this day when is the
chinese new year it's in like late
january february right right everybody's
got a different starter date and so
the jewish new year is another new year
that yeah yeah everybody's got their new
year everybody's got their own new year
the academic calendar has a new year
it's it's september 1st even though they
don't say it it really is that you know
all the academic folks come back from
summer vacation children buy their
school supplies that's in a way a new
year's day for school
if you want to think about it right
that's right and by the way one quick
thing you got a hundred dollars in your
bank account and you go withdraw a
hundred dollars from the cash machine
and the bank tells you what
um don't do this again man
because uh
by the way you think you have a hundred
dollars and you don't
so what you
forgot was the elect what you forgot was
the electric bill came through yesterday
before you withdrew the hundreds before
you were through this hundred you sound
like this has happened to you chuck
so here's the thing you you have no
money left in the bank and that's bad
but what's worse is to have negative
money
yes in the bank and so this whole
concept of negative numbers arose
and made complete sense
once you pass through zero and now
instead of something coming your way you
now owe it
right and so the mathematics began to
mirror commerce and the needs of
civilization as we move forward because
we're doing much more than just counting
things
you know so this is like the birth of
modern accounting
once you find zero that's when you're
able to actually have you know a ledger
sheet that shows you
minus and pluses and all that kind of
yeah it's one of the few places in the
world where it's really good to be in
the black
apparently no other way is it good to be
in the black except on the on the
accounting fee
that's great
so
so now you can go into negatives and
this keeps going with math and you find
other needs of culture and civilization
and science where whole other branches
of math have to be developed and so this
just went on and on and we got
trigonometry all the stuff that you
thought the teacher was just being angry
with you uh giving you these assignments
these are entire branches of math the
zero
started it all
where
it gives you deeper insights into the
operations of nature
absolutely um wow that's uh
that's pretty cool i mean all this just
from
from nothing yeah
all this came from nothing
and so in this way nothing means
something right and what's that what's
that song from the 80s nothing from
nothing leaves nothing
you got to have something
if you won't be with me
nothing from nothing leaves nothing's
nothing i think that's a legit equation
i have to think about that
zero minus zero you just can't start
dividing
right zero because then you end up
dividing by zero and that's that's
illegal
right that's a you've broken the law of
the universe or something but
you decide you divide it too many times
right beetlejuice shows up
[Laughter]
so chuck i just want to bring you up to
bit up to speed on zero that's all yeah
yeah i got to tell you i've never been
more impressed with nothing so this is
cool this is very cool all right this
has been yet another star talk explainer
neil degrasse tyson keep looking up
[Music]